TEA ON A SUNDAY IN RALEIGH.KEEP
THE ZONE.
OPPORTUNITIES BEEN ONE OUT IN
FRONT INTERCEPTED BY CARARTHAT
PLACE IT IN THE TRAPEZOID.
NET.
THERE TRYING TO TAKE ON   THE R
CAROROSLOWER
IF I AM THINKING TOO MUCH.
CAN EASILY DO
SHOP.COM. THE TWO POINTS.
>> I HAVE ONE ON THE BOOTH
RIGHT NOW.
FOR ME THIS IS A DAY FRED IS DO
NOW ASKED ME TODAYA
WHISTLE.
>> HE HAS BEEN COMES OUT OF THE
PENALTY BOX.
ANOTHER, LOW SAVE FROM
ANDERSON.
I WAS TEXT LOOK HOW YOU MATCH
BE TO
HE DELIVERS A HIT IN THE PUCK G
ZONE.
HE IS A GOOD ONE.
A FORMER MY TIME WITH HIM AND H
INTO EVENING. GET A WI
BEHIND.
FREDERICK ANDERSON IS TIED
REIMER GETS ON TOP OF THAT AND
WILL GET AN ASSIST TO COVER THA
THIS PUCK IS BEING PLAYED IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
HE WILL HAVE
HE WILL SEND IT A A
THAT GAME WILL BE PLAYED
TOTALLY DIFFERENT THAN THIS ONE
PERIOD, THIS MAY BE ONE OFF A
FACECETHE DRAW AWAY FROM HURDLE
LOOKING TO CLEAR AND THEY WERE
IN THE SISITHAT
DESPERATION.
PESCI IS WAY UP TOP.
HE IS GOING TO